we turn out a breaking news here at noon
from southeast las vegas an
investigation is now underway
following an officer-involved shooting
happened off of maryland parkway
and silverado ranch hector mejia live on
scene for us with the very latest hi
hector what can you tell us
hey there alex and this is a very fluid
situations trash
situation traffic being diverted as the
situation
changes by the second more police
officers arriving including
unmarked vehicles that's where the
detour is this is silverado ranch it's
closed in both directions right at
pollock
and probably all the way down to
maryland parkway so this is where
investigators are focusing
what's going on right now we don't know
yet the full story
but we know so far confirmed by metro
police is that they're investigating an
officer-involved shooting
and they're also searching for a suspect
who is believed to be armed
and barricaded somewhere in this
neighborhood a police source told 8-8
news now
this was happening at milan apartment
town homes which is right off to the
right
and a lot of activity is going on we
have the police helicopter up ahead
and we have dozens and dozens of
investigators here we don't know about
any injuries but again let me show you
what's going on right now
more police vehicles arriving by the
second that includes the unmarked cars
we're going to bring you updates as we
get them for now reporting live by
silver